this is the Joo underground podcast
number 83 with Echo Charles sitting
across from me so here's I'm not a
huge quote guy but occasionally got to
throw him out there here's one
perseverance alone does not assure
success no amount of stalking would lead
to game in a field that has
none that's a quote from the the I Ching
which is the ancient Chinese text
kind of has some mysterious Origins but
uh believed to have been compiled by a
group of sages I like when you can use
the the term Sage yeah in a legitimate
way not calling some person on Instagram
a sage but to say an ancient Sage yeah
the real one uh group of sages who were
trying to understand you know the nature
of life and the nature of the universe
and whatnot
so you know and perhaps on the jonle
podcast at some point we'll cover the
entire text of the iing
but this the reason that this this
reading
this I I decided hey this might be
something worth bringing up this quote
of perseverance alone is not a sure
success no amount of stalking will lead
to game in a field that has none is
because interestingly right
now in this world
of hustle culture in this world of did
you make up the term toxic productivity
no I thought it was your daughter oh
okay okay maybe my daughter made it up
but you can see how if you're a toxic
productivity human or you're all on
board for the hustle culture which let's
face it hey hustle I'm down right hustle
culture yeah let's go let's get stuff
done let's make things
happen
but this is an important thing to
remember it's in line with that
conversation which we've talked about we
talked about on the game
podcasts you know which game are you
playing you're playing soccer or playing
basketball you know in soccer you can
only score a point maybe two points in
in basketball you can score
30 so what game are you
playing and in this one the what made me
think that this was even more relevant
because I started thinking of being in a
field stalking for game right stalking
for an animal
hunt well when you're stalking
you're crawling you're low crawling
you're sneaking you can't see very much
at
all you certainly can't see the whole
field that you're stalking in in order
to tell whether there's any game in
there or not look you might be following
a trail but you don't know how long that
trail goes for you know how far it goes
you you have no
idea so what happens with us is we it's
very easy for us to get caught up in the
stock it's very easy for us to get
caught up in the
hunt
and it's exciting right it's engaging on
the trail you're you're stalking it's
good you victory's around as far as you
can tell Victory might be around the
next Bush that could be
happening but if you're not
careful you just might be hunting in a
field that has no animals in it there's
no game in
there so you have to detach and I I
realize that I use the term detach all
the time and it's really easy for me to
throw it out there because I know what
I'm talking about so what am I mean what
I mean
here
is actually stopping working for an hour
on a Saturday or for an hour on a Sunday
stop your hustle culture stop your toxic
productivity actually stop
that
and write
down what you're
doing where you're going and how you
plan to get
there that's all it takes right actually
write down where am I right now where am
I right now wait where is it that I want
to
go and then how do I plan to get
there that's what this
is if you write things down it helps you
detach from them and then you can look
and you can say wait a second I know
where I want to be and this job that I'm
in isn't getting me there this path that
I'm on isn't going to get me
there this methodology that I'm using is
not going to get me
there
so once you write this down once you
detach from it once you assess what is
actually happening then you can either
get back to
hunting in the
field cuz you're in the right field in
the correct field or you can go and move
to a different field where there is some
game that you can
hunt that's it that's what I got for
today it's my underground output for
today watch out for
it yeah yeah the hustle culture and I'm
still trying to get a grasp on it um
where if I'm not mistaken tell me what
you think where you hustle okay you have
all these sort of leaders in the
community right who hustle and they're
but they're successful so it's kind of
like and they and they really advocate
for the hustle so then you have certain
followers who embrace the idea of Hustle
but meanwhile they're not getting
success but it doesn't matter because
the culture is the hustle itself so it's
kind of like and then of course social
media and the internet in general sort
of can proliferate just the the the
attitude because of the payoff because
of the additional payoff meaning if you
can if I can hustle if I can uh you know
power through 100 emails today sent out
you know 100 more um made 12 Cold calls
I don't know whatever the whatever we're
doing and if I did all that regardless
of the results regardless of the
mistakes I made or did make regardless
of the result if I did all that that
gets kind of commended like hell yeah
hustle on brother you know they get the
the support so they get a big payoff big
one you know uh uh what do you call
admiration or respect from your peers is
one of the best
yeah this is you're exactly you're
talking ex exactly why I BR bring this
up and you're bringing it to a point
where people try will understand I think
I I didn't do a good job I didn't do
this
Justice here's what you got to watch out
for look everyone says these days you
know you got to enjoy the process right
you got to enjoy the process you like
focus on the process and there's a
reason that people say that and it makes
sense here's the thing if you're
focusing on the
process but there are no results
coming you're making a mistake what when
people say hey just enjoy the
process what they say is you can't go
out and try and sell your widget for one
day and be like we didn't get any sales
or even a week and be like we didn't get
any
sales oh I enjoy the process though I'm
going to go and bang on more doors
tomorrow yeah good job but at a certain
point you've got to assess and say wait
a second I haven't sold any widgets in a
month and a half I keep getting told no
yeah hey I get I get I might need to ask
a 100 people to get two yeses but if I
asked 500 people and I've got no
yeses now you need to start to assess
not just the process but what is the
actual widget that you're selling what
is the actual game that you're in this
is where it can be a problem here's you
know you're a workout guy I'm a workout
guy if you have someone that's following
a program like oh I'm going to do
whatever they're going to do hey from
now on we're going to take the uh we're
going to do high repetition workouts
Okay cool so you start doing that you're
not going to see results tomorrow you're
not going to see results in a week but
if you're doing super
lightweight and very extreme High
repetitions and you're trying to get
bigger and stronger you might be gaining
endurance but you might certainly might
not be getting bigger and you certainly
might not be getting stronger yeah so if
you just embrace the process and you
keep on the grind and you keep doing
these massive High repetition exercises
but you're not getting the results that
you want eventually you need to say oh
my Approach is wrong I need a new
strategy
yeah yeah there was saying there was
this guy s d Stefano he's a trainer he
uh he said something that I totally
agree with where he's like the man who
enjoys walking will walk farther than
the man trying to get to where he's
walking to something along those lines
and I was like yeah that's true and
given now given what you're saying it's
like man the bigger a big picture look
at is like it's kind of a one might say
dichotomy right where it's like a man
who really loves walking and wants to
get somewhere he really has to want to
get to that place as well because if a
man just loves walking he might as well
just walk on the treadmill and then
that's the same as these these hustle
culture guys who are just hustling for
the sake of hustling they're just on a
treadmill they're not going nowhere yeah
see what I'm saying
so yeah that that second part of it I
think is is important you know
especially you know you bring to light
make it a lot more clear and youed to
say this you still say it where you're
like what are you doing right now what
are you doing right now you're like frak
BR you can ask yourself that ask
yourself that question once a day like
what are you doing right now yeah and
bra it kind of helps cuz even just that
simple question which actually seems
kind of ambiguous on the surface bro
that is a deep question yeah yeah and I
think that'll help used to say to those
young seal officers there' be like
Mayhem going on be like what are you
doing right now and you could see they
didn't know what they were doing or
whatever they were doing wasn't making
any sense and they as soon as they ask
themselves
which that is a little excerpt of what
we are doing on the Joo underground
podcast so if you want to continue to
listen go Tojo underground.com And
subscribe and we're doing this to
mitigate our Reliance on external
platforms so we are not subject to their
control and we're doing it so we can
give you more control more interaction
more direct connections better
Communications with us strengthen this
Legion of Troopers that are in the game
with us so thank you it's Joo
underground.com it costs
$818 a month and if you can't afford to
support us we can still support you just
email assistance atjo underground.com
and we'll get you taken care of until
then we will see you
mobilized
Underground